WE'RE ABOUT 15 SECONDS FM
TAKEOFF.
>> 10,8, 7, 6,IN -- 1-
CHING BLUE IGIN'SSHEPARD'S"SPEC
FLIGHT,
OV ITSS -- A
TON 11-MINUTE  JUSEDGE OAC IT'LI
THEY HAVE ENTERED.>> ZERT S LIKE
THIS IS ASUN
LIVE.BRING INITE,
AND COLONEL HATFIELD., WH W WHE
I JUST GET SO ERS OLD.
THT ES.W, YOU KRE HAPPENINGONTH.
WE CAN HES, THEIR
TEMENTINCREDIBLE LLYIT'S INCREDE
TH TIME.THT GEREHTLESSNESS.
WECH THE
PAYIUSRSE W  ANDERW THEY'RE  TH.
OW
CAPSULE, IT TAKES UP AREST WIN
THEY SAY SPACE
ES ABEFORE THE T CK DOWTH J IS U
INARS DE
THE
LL HUGE BURS DUST
HEDESE.ECAUSE D LANDMILE PER
WE'LSO SEE THE BOOSTER
E SPACE CAE THE
BOOSTETHTODAY.ADY FLOWN FOUR
TIMES.REUSABY D
NCE, KNOW, THE
CIENCE FICTI
WE DON'T JASND A LANDINGWEEE BO
ANDINGISIFTH TIS
HE  SHOULBE JUST ANOWD SAY INU.
I' T BE US
DIOINTED TO BEOMIN  TEARTH, BNDR
YOU SPENA BIIMSPACUTESHE STRAIS
E?
H, AS EL WEIGHTLESS.
YOU'VENL SUPERPOWERL STRAHAHAD O
THEY CAN SEE HALFWCR SA P INKNEU
T IT'S
PETENG
TH SOAP
DS
IT'S WONDE
R  HER DAD
DID ITOSE FLIGHT. RACHEL,HAE YOG
OUR E  DON'T KNON HEAR.
THE SONIC BOOM RIE,H TIT
MEIT, R UC
OWI THIN--TILL JOF THEONICOOM.
N CONFIRM  B HLL BLAG ANY TIME
GRAVITY.
ETP FOR A MOMENT AND
LISTEN INTO THIS LANDING
.
IMPRESSIVE INIT
WE SEE A BIT OF FLAME -- SRY
TO CUT YOU OFFELAT ARE
OUND?
OU WER
TALKABFORE WITTHE
EX
SEE ANYTHING JUST HAVE MN E
HOPEFULLY I'LL SEE IE
SOON.
WHAT I WAS SPEAKING OF BEFOR
THE PHILOSOPT ATENS THAT ASTRONA
CHRIS CAN RTSPEAK TO
WHAT HAPPEHE
CURVATUR THE EARTH, SEE
WOTHOUT BORI
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES YOU.
WE H WLIER SPEAK
TO ELOQUENT
LD JUSTTLOVER
TRAVELED TO SPACSPEAT MOST ASTR
THIS "SURVIVOR" VIEW EFFEC AND
MAKESSTEWARDS
THEWAW  PEOPL--
Y CERT
THEY HAVE ENJOYED THEIR JOURNE
>>S AN IDEA OF
COLONIZATI -U
THINK OF IT'SOF
STEPS RM FROM
PEOPLE LIN ATION
THE LAST 21 YEARS, BUT THAT'
I'G WHAT THESE STSILDOIT
I'M DELITHAT MICEL
Y'LL
MERSONAL
WNT THIM.
IN PE NOLOGICAL AND THMA
IM THE TWO BIG
PIECES THATRIKE OVER
R , AND D
SIGNIFICANCE TO WHAT HAPPENED I
>> L T